[Music]
getting into so you talk about
men masculinity which is
here's
we talk we're talking offline
about charting a third course here yeah
when i hear the word masculinity so
i spent years and years
in grad school and counseling so i hear
a lot of toxic masculinity that that
word right yeah
masculinity's destroying everything and
it's things that aren't even
anthropologically correct right
um that we just made it up a few years
ago right and then you get the other
side which is
what i would consider equally damaging
is this almost celebration of neanderth
of just complete idiots
yeah and i i struggle with with finding
a path in the middle here and it looks
like you have so walk me through what
how would you describe how would you
define masculinity for folks well this
is really important because you're right
you hear a lot of things like um
well you said toxic masculinity uh
tyrannical patriarchy you know down with
the patriarch you hear things like rape
culture
you know things that aren't
related to that are called that you know
it's kind of weird and
really really what i what i see it being
is is a
a movement to lump all masculinity in as
toxic or harmful or destructive so the
american psychological association came
out with a study
uh that at the end of the day if you
root everything away they basically said
that the attributes that we would
normally consider masculine by nature so
i think it was competitiveness dominance
maybe aggression
and stoicism
are inherently harmful
well they're not yeah and
and when people say toxic masculinity i
know what some people are saying i know
they're saying what what's again some
people are saying that some masculinity
or if you take it to the extreme it can
be toxic i actually don't disagree with
that but i don't use that term because
it's
what are we even talking about the fact
that we even need to sit here and define
it is is why i'm not going to use that
with that term because i don't think
it's used in the right
context and i don't think it has the
right motive behind it so so let's let
me say this
and i'm going to set the record straight
here masculinity is
amoral
it's not good it's not some people say
oh mask we need it so good no it it's
not good it's just as it is it is what
it is yeah yeah you know we have i was
talking with my son i told you you
started a podcast and we were talking
about testosterone yeah and i read up on
a lot of this because i want to stay in
the know and um you know
young young
boys
fetuses babies newborns
even in utero are introduced to higher
levels of testosterone than our female
counterparts
and that changes us biologically
physiologically it changes who we are
and it causes us to
um have certain characteristics um
secondary sex characteristics like we're
bigger we're stronger we're faster bone
density muscle mass
but also the way that we behave in the
way that we interact with the world
and and it's amoral it just is is it's
how we utilize it and that's what i call
manliness gotcha so a man
can harness his masculinity for
productive outcomes that's somebody
who's acting like a man anything else is
male you can be a male you know that's a
that's a that's a biological birthright
right you're either a male or you're a
female right
then you have masculinity and how you
use your masculinity those
characteristics caused by the hormones
flooding through our bodies is what
determine if we're being manly or not
so manly for you is not a pejorative
mainly for you is like it's a
that is a thing to aspire to kind of
like i hear i you know working with kids
there's a lot of
fathers
fewer dads right yeah they can father a
kid right but becoming somebody's dad
that's a different thing right so
there's a bunch of people who can be
male sure
manliness
when applied appropriately looks like
what it's the next level uh let me say
what it's not it's not you know wearing
a flannel shirt and and chopping wood
and disagreed yeah
i'm not saying you shouldn't okay
come on man it's it's not having a beard
again i'm not saying that you shouldn't
listen
i haven't shaved like in 11 months this
is all i got man
uh it's been probably like 11 minutes
for me
dude you used to have this long sucker
yeah it looked awesome yeah jiu jitsu
got in the way oh did it or my beard got
in the way of jiu-jitsu yeah
um
yeah so
people say well you know it's going to
the gym look no no no i mean strength is
important
but it's how you use the strength
you know if you if if you go to the gym
and you're jacked and you're and you use
it to beat people yeah okay that's not
being manly i mean you might have some
masculinity in there because you know
you're you're strong and you're big and
you have those those hormones but that's
not being manly no i don't think anybody
would suggest it is yeah
uh but but alternatively if you witness
a car accident and you're able to pry
open a door with your muscles and pull
somebody out of the car because you're
exhibiting bravery courage risk-taking
and the physical strength to be able to
deal with it that's manly behavior
so manly manliness is it's a character
it is it's developed it's earned it's
almost something practiced right well
that's the best way to get better at
anything you can't just be manly like
you have to actually practice it so a
lot of times people say
they'll say to me um
you know i nobody needs another man to
tell him how to be a man no that's the
furthest thing from the truth i need a
picture of what this looks like that's
exactly opposite yes reality yes so my
sons i've got three sons i've also got a
little girl
and they they need instruction yes
if they don't get it
then they have they have the potential
of going off course well see and i'll
i'll even go one step further they will
get it it will be from you or from
somebody they'll get an instruction
manual it might be faulty that's it yeah
maybe they will pick one up yeah and so
i love there's a i think it's maybe an
old adler quote an old psychologist
quote said i thought i could take away
somebody's depression anxiety and they
would be well i found they were empty
that's who they were i had to give them
my tools to learn how to practice to be
live a life of joy live a life of
relationship of connection whatever
right similarly i can choose to teach my
son what a man looks like and here's
what value looks like and if your
character looks like
or not
and somebody else will fill that vacuum
right and so he's going to use his
masculinity for
destructive for gain yes which becomes
yeah yeah because but again and that's
where people say well see that's toxic
masculinity look i understand what
you're saying i don't disagree but i
don't use terms that are designed or at
least hijacked to paint all masculinity
is toxic that's right and i think we're
that that's i mean that's one of my core
missions here is we've got to chart a
third wave of instead of brushing
everything sideways right i mean with
one one one swipe right yeah
you